Eddie nots taking off in the middle of
the night from kuala lumper airport in a
Boeing airliner just like Malaysia
Airlines flight mh370 did at the weekend
gear up
this is a simulator and the cockpit
a mock-up of a 737 are the controls
alistair rosen shine a commercial
airline pilot for 30 years and a man
with a possible explanation as to why a
jet and 239 people have apparently
disappeared so once we were in our
simulated cruise over the South China
Sea
we played out the scenario so you think
that there is some kind of
depressurization which you can recreate
now what happens after that I'll
demonstrate depressurization they should
put their health their headset their
oxygen masks on
but instead they commence the turn on to
the reciprocal heading so they're trying
to go back to 12 and because they know
there's something wrong yeah they're
turning left back towards polygon 4 and
at this point having set the heading
they then pass out unconscious so
they're concentrating on getting back
meantime the depressurization is so
great that they lose consciousness
meanwhile what's happening to the plane
the aircraft will continue on autopilot
just as it doing right now turning on to
this heading the one that they
pre-selected staying at the same flight
level and burning off fuel so where's
the plane now where does it end up the
plane in this case would end up
it's got 3,000 miles worth of fuel on
board it would take it to about the
middle of the Indian Ocean and as
unlikely as it may seem it has happened
before coming to helios airlines in
greece in 2005 where there was a
depressurization the oxygen didn't
function properly so the pilots passed
out in that scenario the camming crew
and passengers remain conscious for some
time 15-20 minutes afterwards before
they passed out and then eventually the
aircraft ran out of fuel and descended
into the ground with mh370 apparently
vanishing and nothing conclusive to say
why all theories have to be considered
David Bowden Sky News